a solar eclipse happens when a new moon
moves between the Earth and the Sun
blocking some or all of the sun's rays
from reaching the earth by cosmic chance
even though the Sun is 400 times wider
than the moon it's also 400 times
farther away therefore the two objects
appear the same size in our sky
astronomers are able to predict eclipses
because the Earth and Moon have very
predictable orbits why then isn't there
in Eclipse every month the moon's orbit
is usually tilted a few degrees north or
south in relation to the earth when the
moon does eclipse the Sun it casts two
types of shadows on earth a smaller
darker shadow known as the Umbra and a
larger shadow known as the penumbra
there are four types of solar eclipses
the first and most spectacular is a
total eclipse when the moon completely
covers the Sun surface a total eclipse
can only be seen if you're standing
within the umbral shadow that's why the
imaginary line created by this shadow as
it races across Earth is known as the
path of totality people within the
penumbral shadow see only a partial
eclipse the second type from this view
outside the path of totality the moon
passes in front of the Sun off-center
never fully covering its surface third
an annular eclipse occurs when the moon
passes directly in front of the Sun
however unlike a total eclipse the moon
appears too small to fully cover the Sun
the moon's orbit is elliptical so
sometimes it's closer to Earth and
sometimes it's farther away last a
hybrid eclipse is when the moon's
position between the Earth and Sun is so
we balanced that the curvature of the
earth plays a role the moon will be
farther away from some parts of Earth
along the eclipses path resulting in an
annular eclipse in other parts the moon
will be just close enough to fully cover
the Sun resulting in a total eclipse
while a total solar eclipse happens
somewhere on earth every year or two any
given point on earth experiences the
event only about once every four hundred
years we interrupt this video for an
important safety announcement looking
directly at the Sun even during an
eclipse can cause permanent eye damage
fortunately there are ways to enjoy an
eclipse safely the easiest is to use
certified eclipse watching glasses which
are shaded thousands of times darker
than typical sunglasses you can also
look at the Eclipse indirectly by making
a pinhole viewer simply poke a small
hole in a piece of cardboard hold the
cardboard up to the Sun allowing the
sun's image to be projected onto a flat
surface be sure to look only at the
surface and not through the cardboard
just before the moon completely covers
the Sun low-lying valleys on the moon's
edge will be the only spots that
sunlight continues to pass through these
remaining brilliant shafts of light
known as Baily's beads will disappear
one after another and finally a single
bead of light remains known as the
diamond ring signaling that you're just
seconds away from experiencing totality
once the last bead disappears and the
moon completely covers the sun's surface
the view through your Eclipse glasses
will be pitch-black totality achieved
at this point none of the sun's rays are
reaching your eyes and it's the only
time that it's safe to take off your
glasses remember to put your Eclipse
glasses back on before any of the sun's
rays start to peek through again any
sunlight reaching your eyes even for a
few seconds can cause serious damage
while an eclipse can last a few hours
totality typically occurs for less than
three minutes animals and plants have
also been known to alter their behavior
during a total eclipse songbirds may
stop singing crickets may start chirping
and flowers may even start to close up
we won't always be able to see total
solar eclipses the moon moves about
one-and-a-half inches away from Earth
each year it's estimated that in about a
billion years the moon will be too far
away from Earth to completely cover the
Sun
[Music]